so my boyfriend turned red pill and at
this point we haven't spoke for about a
month and I can't cope with the fact
that someone who I saw is so
compassionate and thoughtful and
intelligent so caring and open-minded
just completely did a 180. they were
just so supportive and caring and even
when I would have my self-sabotaging
episodes they still loved me I feel like
red pill men stole my future husband
from me because I really really thought
this was the person I don't want anybody
I don't want to be with anybody
I could just treat me that way all right
I wanna it's like I don't wanna be with
anyone she wants all this sympathy okay
then die alone just like the men do oh
my gosh